this episode brought to you by Stardust
fan sharing video reactions to movies TV
and trailers yeah chill trainer oh my
god this is the greatest game in the
world
yeah Tomb Raider it's 1997 yeah lay
across awesome you're awesome we're
across yeah ah if only you existed in
real life don't I though
lera from one of the most revolutionary
games ever made challenging the world of
male dominated main characters creating
a new timeless icon that can change and
evolve but none of that matters to your
holy fortune yield mind does it no you
just want to look at with your limited
knowledge of pixel technology finds sexy
Oh
your smooth pointy face your
terrifyingly large lips and your breasts
oh so square you know nothing will ever
be sexier than me never never
hello I'm gonna stablish a critic guy
remember it so you don't have to
there's a saying when it comes to video
game movies and goes something like this
video game movies suck so many classic
titles that change gaming as we know and
often result in painful annoying or just
downright forgettable films yeah there's
always fans up there who insists they're
not as bad as everyone says they are
Mortal Kombat kid maad Warcraft it's
like the game so that's good right Max
Payne okay everybody hear that one but
Prince of Persia I didn't walk out on it
and then those films like Lara Croft
Tomb Raider
based on the groundbreaking franchise
Tomb Raider followed the adventures of
millionaire our key kinda gist Lara
Croft played here by Angelina Jolie well
it did well at the box office it's
rarely brought up as a good video game
movie and got panned hard by critics
when it came out I expected more out of
something based off of t-rex and giant
zombie battles okay it's clear this is
gonna be a ridiculous outing and it's
gonna have fans and haters no matter
what but is there value to watching it
years later does it hold up in any
respect is it just a dated product of
the times or much like leras TV tray
rack is it somehow both let's journey
back to the early two-thousands to find
out this is Lyra Croft Tomb Raider we
open with Lara hanging around on the set
of legends of the Hidden Temple your
quest is to work in a robot fight
training montage and shall we see in the
first body minutes of screen time
haha years from now will be the only
action movie associated with using wires
they didn't wait long and the stupid
don't worry is everybody no bullets top
metal this calls for a celebratory gum
flip yeah one more we hope you're
enjoying the Tomb Raider stunt show
watch it she pretends to be overpowered
as convincingly as Bela Lugosi fights an
octopus this is what a shock just a
training exercise in case she comes
across real killer robots in ancient
tombs and if you're wondering how she
can afford a training setup so elaborate
it's because she's basically a mix of
Bruce Wayne's stupid rich money mixed
with Indiana Jones's side job except she
doesn't do it to preserve history or a
venture dead parents or anything she
doesn't because it's just cool and I'm
not gonna lie I'm weirdly okay with that
lera in this movie is a straight-up
adrenaline junkie she does everything
for the thrill of it and though again at
play she's blown me away in other movies
I have to admit a lot of the characters
credibility is because of Joe Lee's
performance you see back in the day she
was kind of a wild star making out in
public filming her own drug deals going
to S&M clubs even carrying around a vial
of her husband's blood around her neck
since then she's calmed down and got
more serious but yeah when she fights
giant robots rides motorcycles and
bungee jumps in her own living room just
because I totally buy that she's crazy
enough to do it just because I'm
surprised she hasn't travelled to the
moon to get space cheese though her
Butler played by Chris Barry doesn't
always approve of her wild ways I've
only tried to turn you into a lady and a
lady should be modest yes a lady should
be modest now if you'll excuse me I'm
off to the Children's Museum like this
meanwhile on the evil fast-moving clouds
of Venice the Illuminati are talking
about finding the ancient artifact that
will give them supreme power because
what do you really think the plot to mm
one's Tomb Raider would be this is mr.
Powell played by Iain Glen who's done
this ancient mysterious cryptic talked
so much he can make an episode of Dora
the explora sound epic we are working
is based on ancient cosmological models
we will have our answer in time for the
relevant planetary alignment we will
find booths we will have possession of
the key in one week yes indeed now on to
the next order of business what sex is
your assistant it's been driving us nuts
for days Lera gets news of this from her
Butler but she's not exactly in the best
mood it's an adventure time come on grab
your friends it's nothing but pyramids
and sand I know gets everywhere in the
cracks not like here here everything is
soft do you know what day it is hurry
yes gazpacho soup day
it looks like it's the anniversary of
her father's death a death that still
haunts her to this day I'll cut you a
good dream this nightmare awakened
something in her though something hidden
under the stairs let me just push that
corpse of Harry Potter out of the way
it's a clock of some kind which she
gives to her computer expert Bryce I do
not want to know what he's doing with
that toy in his bed what's that smell
for then I have no joke I just love that
line well I need some coffee
decaf latte with nonfat milk he's a
science question genius how does decaf
coffee wake you up where's that
you know for a finder of ancient relics
she says delicate as well a hammer to a
clock she finds something of importance
inside and takes it to a friend of hers
who works in an auction house three
hundred thousand two million three two
million four hundred thousand ladies
paid two million four hundred thousand
pounds 2,500,000 pounds in a new place
at two million five hundred thousand
pound few money on toast she comes
across an old friend of me named Alex
played by then unknown actor Daniel
Craig you know I think it's really cool
we still have a day job you are still
pretending to be a photojournalist she's
still pretending to be American are you
still pretending to be an archaeologist
you stole my prayer wheel stole from you
you know that's funny you know it's not
like you ever really owned them or
anything I think they're in a
competition to see whose accent could be
more insulting to the others nationality
it's all just a business hey you know
that generator glorious guy right
there's a moaning in mine actually this
is kind of weird he's invested excitable
giving a shit about what he's talking
about you are Daniel Craig right at
first it looks like her friend can't
help her but later that night he refers
her to mr. Powell she goes to visit
Powell as it's sounding more and more
like anyone rich in this universe is
secretly a Tomb Raider was mr. Powell
dude he's a lawyer
Tiny's long lonesome a lawyer he
invested a Bitcoin okay
I'm Ashley's associate mr. Pimm's mr.
panners like the beverage that bit one
nowhere next scene very interest
but the origin of this clock completely
eludes me this is a pleasurable torment
my ignorant amuses me that line is so
ridiculous even the film makes fun of it
my ignorant amuses me oh you do it's
amuses me yes he also said don't blink
in the cameras your lover as stated
before Alera spends her evenings bungee
jumping in her own living room hoping in
no way an action sequence breaks out in
the middle of it you know I was gonna
make a joke about a millionaire having
the worst security possible but judging
by that look she was probably waiting
for someone to break in to give her some
excitement
she is so hungry for shit to happen it's
like a robber coming across an unlocked
door and seeing this go ahead take it
you know actually I'm good I'm just come
back anytime
boy John woos reboot of a pig in the
city is a lot more intense I thought
it'd be the finest killers here shoot
around the door rather than through it
just in case II can fly this action is a
lot of fun and it looks great but I'm
not exactly sure what's up with this
shot
what's she turning into a werewolf or
maybe it's one of those comedic routines
where the person changes every time the
light goes out what was this guy's plan
anyway first in hoping she was in that
room and then just hang there awkwardly
something these guys plan this out just
when you think this scene can get more
hilariously badass
I love you
you
hey guys here's the best reactions to
what I just reviewed this week I was
very skeptical when
squareness of all people said that they
were going to be rebooting the games but
I was thoroughly impressed wait
you're reviewing the movie aren't you
well it's not that great of a movie I
was about ready to fall asleep and
watching this it's so boring I liked it
I love the character of Lara Croft I
loved the action I loved the adventure
aspects of it nobody was so dumb but
somehow Angelina Jolie transcends it all
is it the worth amputation of the 2013
game but Angelina Jolie was good in this
movie you have opinions a lot of
opinions about movies TV shows even
trailers there's so much to talk about
you get emotional about them just like
anybody gets emotional about them well
now you don't have to wait to get that
raw emotion straight to the Internet
why because we got star does app it
allows you instantly to film your
reactions to movies TV shows and even
trailers happy angry confused whatever
it is and whatever your reaction is
Stardust is there to show it some of the
wildest and craziest reactions are on
there and there's so much fun to watch
there's a lot of variety endless
possibilities and they're definitely
worth checking out I even using myself
this week I give reactions to the
trailer for Slender Man Winchester and
of course Tomb Raider it's there to get
the first and best reaction that you got
it's a ton of fun and 100% free so check
out other people's opinions as well as
sharing your own also stay tuned
afterwards to see how you can be in the
next nostalgia critic
hey guys just let you know real fast I
will be appearing at Comic Con in
Birmingham Alabama
January 26 to the 28th not only am i
coming but Rob is coming and Malcolm is
coming and Tamara is coming we're
bringing a whole great big group and
we're gonna film something there as well
it's a wonderful con we've been there
before we're really excited to return so
hopefully we will see you guys there
guy steal the clock away from her and
deliver it to Powell and I'm immediately
looking forward to this guy getting his
ass kicked not that there's anything
wrong with meditation but we see the bad
guy doing it admit it you're more
looking forward to him getting his ass
kicked
lady Laura crow I woke up this morning
and I just hated everything you could
have just said Billy Bob thorn came to
visit Lera apparently gets a letter from
her father when he was still alive if
you're reading this letter I am no
longer with you and I miss you forever I
know you loved one I did my Anthony
Hopkins voice oh I'm writing this in my
Anthony Hopkins voice the triangle of
light was forged from metal found in the
crater of a meteor the people of the
light build a great city in this crater
where their worship the triangle it gave
its possessor a path that could be used
for good or great evil ancient powerful
if people gets it we're screwed Triforce
of wisdom Triforce of power excuse me
princess this really is the video game
portion of the movie isn't it so she has
to go to Cambodia to get half of the
triangle she of course travels the best
way she knows how delightfully dumb
thank you boys
we owe you Kim Possible for saving us
from Dragon and she go she finds
Palestine up with Alex to look for the
same thing as these incredibly rich
millionaires use their expensive
high-tech machinery of people pulling on
ropes couldn't want those training
robots be like it's done
that'll make it go faster thanks Greg
Laura's overrated she's good don't get
me wrong but she's in it for the glory
there's I'm in it for the money
see this is why dr. Jones get stuff done
he does it for both fortune and glory
kid Lehrer sneaks in ahead of them and
comes across a mysterious child snooping
around as well
good target
she's bet and of course the old flower
poling leaving you to the smoothest ball
you ever had in your life crap they do
like their cliches Lyra watches as the
competition tries to get the triangle
but she puts together that drop digging
in the wrong place that is not the true
I we can do it my way or we can all come
back in time to the next alignment and
you're welcome to try and kill me then
you know say another 5000 years only my
lips will still be around by that point
they eventually believe her and throw
her the key leading to
you know I have no idea what's going on
but it looks awesome for some reason I'm
really okay with their action scenes
being very swing based no it's releasing
a mummy sequel not just kidding we all
know those aren't coming
Clara cramps the triangle and Craig
grants the key awaking okay this is a
little tail spinach but I'm still on
board the body garden he used you as a
literal bodyguard can't say it's false
advertising they managed to fight off
the guards but their troubles aren't
done yet
so it makes no sense why they would
slowly walk away from something so
gigantic and huge and going to kill them
but at the same time I can't argue it is
still kind of cool in fact I might as
well do I don't know why that's just
cool count after using all her ammo on
one phase he easily switches to another
coup but she uses shitty early 2000
slow-mo to kill him surprisingly keeping
this fight kind of short but she's not
done running yet as Trey corners her at
a waterfall we going to shoot me at it
she did a wedding darling right here off
of this dead rat here she escapes to a
nearby town where she gets healed up
drink it tastes quite bad yeah she's
good for you see why does magic healing
tea harder for me to go along with them
fighting ape statues I guess some
stupidity we just won't believe more
than others
she calls mr. Powell to figure out what
the hell they're gonna do seeing how he
has the clock and she has the triangle
miss some idea without each other we are
quite useless at this point we should
have a business meeting you mean you'd
love to have another opportunity to try
and kill me well that's all perhaps I'm
sorry I know technically this is a dumb
conversation but it's weirdly smooth - I
love that their connection is more than
just villain versus hero they have a lot
in common personality wise but there's
still their own unique characters even
when they meet up to discuss terms you
know there's a bizarre trust and
understanding of the other even though
they constantly try to kill one another
it just makes their connection much more
interesting than your typical
run-of-the-mill adventure flick we can
be partners and go for the big prize yes
what hmm since you could set right so
many wrong I don't think you sit here do
you things get interesting though when
he reveals her father was part of the
Illuminati and kept it from her for
years
he had a great many secrets not from me
especially from you the triangle gives
its possessor to move back and forth
through time time-travel huh you're
pushing your dumb little movie this
level of dumb is okay this level of dumb
is not and you're somewhere at this
level of dumb
hello Alex I suppose you think I'm a
greedy unscrupulous okay I protest there
is way more naked Daniel Craig stepping
out of the shower the naked Angelina
Joli hopefully his awful American accent
can distract me well the money that's
true I guess now for a cold shower
it does add to the count not one but two
alliances of convenience in this movie
as Lara teams up with Powell to find the
ancient time power thingy time to save
universe again then is it I guess that's
something we did I thought we just found
it but apparently saving the universe
multiple times we can put down on our
resume Oh what do I care when this shot
is up next
that's so cool Arnold Schwarzenegger
almost made it
I spun about it and once again the kid
disappears
she's also Keyser sze Croft literally
rings the bell to be led into whatever
the hell this is supposed to be
it's a time story time is broken here mm
truth be told this is where the movie
starts to flounder a little bit it's
already a little tough to follow what
this thing does or how it works
so when pal kills the leader of the
Illuminati to take its power we don't
really know what that power is is it
just time travel if so how is it harvest
and what was powell or the Illuminati's
plan for it it sounds like they already
control everything and the soldiers are
quicker they okay with Powell ruling
them so what's really gonna change well
it looks like even Powell is confused
about how it works so we forces Lara to
figure it out using some double-o
leverage wow you seem so bored and
disinterested in being stabbed
that's the Daniel Craig I remember and
apparently it's spreading because even
Lera seems pretty mad about him getting
axed
you better be ready because I clearly
wasn't can we do it take two I clearly
had no emotion when he died she finds
the missing piece in the clock which
that's them both to a giant pyramid they
have to race up to get the ultimate
power because if it's good enough for
the opening of ducktales it's got to be
good enough here she grabs it and it
teleports her to her father for reasons
and he explains why he never told her
about being in the Illuminati you're
only a child you never mentioned it not
once in the fierceness of my own battles
I strove to tell you only that which
would inspire you and keep you safe and
you've clearly tried to keep yourself
safe ever since she's told though she
should destroy the triangle as she
should not manipulate time for herself
she completely agrees right after she
manipulates time for herself
I feel like you could place both hands
on that handle to turn it but its
current - Wow those cards must be so
comfiest did you throw the knife away
from him and it landed in his chest
no hey we did it but Powell reveals that
of course he killed her father and stole
the watch with her mother's picture in
it
agreed whoever said yes to that accent
is insane oh you were stabbed weren't
you no guns
yeah just one man bleeding to death
against a woman who's basically already
defeated him
you know I think that stab actually made
me feel better oh boy oh my my need to
flip things I feel like that's kind of
both our weaknesses she of course
defeats him but she still has to find a
way to get out of there fast
yeah I'm not even kidding though this is
the next edit now is a bit of a jump in
fact the whole film is suddenly on
marathon time she's in a fancy dress
shocking the butler she goes to visit
her father's grave one more time and she
comes back in to see they have guns
ready for her to fight the robot again
all in a matter of 40 seconds they just
freeze on this image like yep that's
what two Raiders all about pointing guns
at a training robot um
neat I guess I can't think of any other
way I would end this movie
apart from answering who that kid was
from earlier how did layer a dream where
the clock was why did the triangle take
her to her father went in she used it to
save his life as well as avoid all this
shit from happening what the hell was
that damn machine supposed to do did it
even do it what exactly was the
Illuminati's plan why do they need to
run up this giant pyramid why any of it
why anything that happened in this movie
because this is the source material they
had a work off of and based on that I'm
satisfied don't get me wrong it doesn't
make a whole lot of sense and it could
use a little more depth but what I found
perfectly serviceable and entertaining
leras a fun character the action scenes
are cool the actors are charismatic and
work well off each other
I surprisingly enjoy this for exactly
what it is a video game movie it takes
us so seriously but not too seriously
and while Tomb Raider will evolve and
change over the years this is a perfect
cinematic representation of what Tomb
Raider was in the early 2000s in my
opinion I think this is a good video
game flick and I'm shocked more people
don't talk about how much fun it is
it's not anything fantastic but as video
game movies go good is fantastic so go
check out what I consider a damn cool
flick
I'm the Nostalgia Critic I'm a tick are
you sure you're not attracted to me
anymore
sorry Lera I have passed your perky
pixelation and had elevated to a higher
form of love isn't that right minecraft
woman a whole Minecraft woman you
understand whoa minecraft hallucination
again when will people wake up
hey guys here's even more reactions to
what I just reviewed this week it's
directed by Simon West who directed
Conair so it's kind of female Indiana
Jones Angie she's got a bud and Daniel
Craig Jen versus James Bond usually
Jolie is gotta be the best Lara Croft
I've ever seen
the young courageous American accent is
fucking terrible oh it's bad but
enjoyably bad this film might be worth
checking out just for that one shower
scene you know the scene I'm talking
about and don't pretend you didn't like
it this is why movies based on video
games do not work unless it's animated
and called Becca valve then it's fucking
awesome you want your reaction to be in
the next nostalgia critic next week on
doing the top 11 good Adam Sandler
movies so your job is to find an Adam
Sandler movie you like you know they're
out there and film your reaction to it
just download the Stardust app at the
link below follow us at nostalgia critic
record your reaction and then tweet it
to us with this hashtag or use Facebook
the ones we like best we'll make it in
the next nostalgia critic video we
absolutely love going through and seeing
everybody's different reactions the
over-the-top one's the funny ones
there's such a wide variety out there
and we love watching them and you will
too so download the app get out there
and show us your crazy reactions
Lara no the place is coming down
hey Doug Walker here doing charity shout
out and this week we are doing the brain
and behavior Research Foundation since
1987 this foundation has awarded 380
million dollars to fund more than 5,500
grants to more than 4,500 scientists
around the world they are the nation's
top non-government funders of mental
health research grants they're committed
to alleviating the suffering caused by
mental illness and awarding grants that
will lead to advances and breakthroughs
in scientific research the foundation
funds the most innovative ideas in
neuroscience and psychiatry to better
understand the causes and develop new
ways to treat brain and behavioral
disorders if you look at their site in
their YouTube page you can see the wide
variety of people opportunities and ways
they've helped in the past they're a
wonderful group and deserve a ton of
attention click the link below and see
how far your donation can go
you